hi guys I'm Greg hi guys I'm John we're
gonna watch the trailer today for the
bad bat
Sheila bad bets not the bad [ __ ] the
bad batch baby bad bet this movie has
Jason mamacita Keanu wick Giovanni
ravioli and jim Kerr Texas oh they're
gonna summary the whole thing
[Music]
whoa not come any more relevant time the
chaos of this world is fast and
unknowable you like to think you can
understand it but we can't I can't
oh all of us here we weren't good enough
Ricky out hard enough young enough all
the things you started and put you right
here with me and here is bad bad do you
really want the solution
oh whoa here's the thing being good bad
[Music]
placing it depends on how you stand in
next week I have a cool life yeah being
good or bad you know that is not a bad
accent from Kiana rejas not a bad accent
for Keanu Reeves yeah yeah really now it
would not do the best access have I got
enough it of everything like intense
three gun training also learn to
maximalism yeah that was a really good
accident kyo mainly intrigued to see
Keanu Reeves but yeah the weight of
style was it's like that b-movie
grindhouse meet Nicolas wounded rep in
July yeah it looks like some kind of
hypnotic exploitation yeah yeah oh yeah
like I don't really I hope it's cool
yeah I hope it's cool good movies like
this tend to make cooler trailers and
cool movies yeah yeah I'm still I still
don't know exactly what the executions
gonna be like it looks really different
from her first movie this looks more
like kind of crazy and apocalyptic like
a girl walk someone I definitely takes
its time it is very compelling but is
more airing and yeah fleshed you know
well let's see what I'm wondering about
is I feel like there's going to be a lot
of style and fuse and a lot of like
themes to explore I feel like with
movies like this where they can kind of
lack of keeping up a good plot moving
along yeah I feel like sometimes they
get caught up in a lot of its own little
things that's fascinated with rather
than yeah something kind of concise
moving forward yeah yeah that's
definitely something you know like girl
walks home alone is not a super light
keeps the plot movie and a movie like
you know and and this looks more music
that'll work yeah yeah but I can see how
you know there's
concern of movies like news getting sort
of I guess muddy or meander II we're
like yeah keep the slob moving sometimes
they'll just sort of hang out and
building exercises and they'll be like
oh yeah the plot I hope that doesn't I
mean it looks cool the main actress is
Suki Waterhouse yeah I mean said
introducing her I've never heard of her
before she looks like she's gonna be
that cool you know Rodriguez area sexy
badass numb cacao hair oh yeah yeah and
this is like a like Jason mo doesn't
speak once in this trailer I wouldn't be
surprised he was just a quiet dude but I
feel like this is a cool kind of role to
throw Jason Momoa for a modern-day flick
oh yeah you know cuz anyway after all we
we mainly loved him from his first
season a game with the room now he's
awful man we still don't know what he's
gonna be like as Aquaman we still have
no idea I'm actually more interested to
see him in this than I am an Aquaman
abyss boy yeah because there's like you
know Aquaman you know there are certain
things he can do and there's only so
much of like a character he could be but
this is like a weird Punk movie yeah I
know so like he's got probably rein to
be a character and Keanu Reeves is
playing like I don't know exactly I like
I'm really intrigued he seems like he's
some type of criminal warlord or
something like that yeah underground
hierarchy he has here I was actually
thinking about this the other day I was
driving out of County did play a bad guy
once and I think this movie was called
the watch now not the watch wasn't a cop
movie it is him and James Spader The
Watcher yeah watch The Watcher gotta
remember that for next Motown he played
a bad guy in it and I thought he was
like a [ __ ] performance ed oh no no I'm
like him and I was really bad calories
is much older now he's in his fifties
and a lot of times actors like see on
Ariza like at this age Arab are probably
even stronger actors now yeah you know
like I think John Blake is his best
performance he's done and that came
later in his career yeah and seeing this
role Mike okay it's cool plan an action
role this is a performance role for
Keanu Reeves where we're not going to
to kill people but to watch and be kind
of evil in some aspects one bowling hair
kind of minister oh yeah it looks
sinister and sort of me allistic and and
you know it almost reminded me like Mad
Max in certain way I did that not hot
sorting exactly it's not like
post-apocalyptic but kind of feels like
that you know yeah you can feel the heat
and how much distance there is and you
know she's like seeing that beat-up car
and you're like I hope that car is gonna
make it yeah yeah where she gets her arm
cut off or something dude ah she's
wielding guns and [ __ ] there's gonna be
a hot sexy character that one yes looks
nuts I think we did get a glimpse or two
of Jim Carrey in this trailer finally
he's called hermit as per IMDB and he
might be that crazy lookin dude
wandering with a shopping cart not to do
with a shopping cart
how that might be Jim Carrey I wonder
why the trailer didn't credit Jim Carrey
like Diego Luna is also in this this
looks like what would happen if the
purge [ __ ] up the whole world movie
looks really cool to me I'm not making a
very entry but it got a surprisingly big
cast yeah yeah especially for like you
know the second movie from a you know
yeah
only just introduced director for like
an exploitation films again like these
level of acting at Jim Carrey there
Chiana reads those are two pretty big
names to be in a [ __ ] movie and these
people I just get divided the casting of
this movies like these people are
probably interested in making this
movement yeah I don't know like not just
oh yeah I'll take a job you know match
man
alright guys rigged well what do you
think of the trailer to new the channel
shout out to you subscribe to the real
rejects and shout out to John on reason
to Jerry on Twitter and Instagram
he's also the social media jerk is
shouting out to Facebook and of the real
rejects in bloom house shout out to Anna
Paquin Anna Paquin the real Sookie yeah
trick or treat man good stuff I met
Hannah Paquin once really where to grow
that's exciting were you watching x-men
she was x-men tting me you know what I
mean like having a complex ideological
argument about humans
I've been punching you a lot sadly yes
pretty cool astray I'm not God